what was the worst job you had to do the
best job
but the worst job was I worked at Burger
King when I was 14 years old and I would
do the closing shift and that was from
like 6 p.m till about two in the morning
and in Ontario where I lived
Ottawa borders Quebec in Ontario the
drinking age is 19. you can see where
I'm going with this
the drinking age in Quebec is 18 and
that year made all the difference to all
these kids and so they would go get
completely drunk they would come back
they would come to the Burger King you
know you would see all these kids you
went to high school with can you imagine
how mortifying it is you know you're
working there in this get up
and they would light that place on fire
vomit everywhere puking pooing peeing
and when the thing shuts down at one
o'clock you know you got to clean that
all up
all of it changing the garbage taking it
out it was
um a grind
and it really teaches you okay I do not
want this job
I don't want to but it's funny that that
didn't push you towards the stability
and the security of the middle class
like do you have any good examples of
that have those around me I was so
ashamed
I could have never built a relationship
where I could have seen those
interactions to want that and so my
desires were framed by these two random
rich people that lived in my town who
I'd never met
and what I read in magazines about
people like Bill Gates and Warren
Buffett